Okay.
I want the day to talk about about,
um,
cyber aeration,
but above all resistance in
Europe during World War Two.
And I'll talk mostly about France
because that's where there's been so much
written about.
Um,
and also I,
because France coming to grips
with the Vichy past was not,
uh,
was not,
an evident thing.
It was something that took a long time.
There was a process of co
collective and official,
uh,
repression,
about what had happened.
And so I want to talk about
that cause it's again,
I mean histories have
their histories and that's,
uh,
I've been around here long enough that I,
that I,
I,
you know,
I can remember all of this happening,
not the war obviously,
but,
uh,
thank you.
But,
but,
uh,
but France coming to grips with its past.
So I want to talk about that.
We haven't talked about
France and long time.
I want to talk about that.
Uh,
but first let me just say a couple things.
Um,
that,
I mean,
other countries had their resistance,
uh,
resistors as well.
Uh,
it was obviously the most successful
case of resistance was that of Yugoslavia
or ex Yugoslavia,
uh,
because you know,
well before the end of the war,
Tito Marshal Tito and his partisans,
um,
taking advantage of,
of,
uh,
the mountains of ex Yugoslavia where
we're able to pin down entire German
divisions and with a
weapons parachuted in,
uh,
by the allies and with entire,
you know,
moving hospitals,
uh,
we're able to,
to launch the most effective,
um,
uh,
resistance,
arguably a in Europe.
And of course,
I mean the,
the case of the Soviet Union,
you know,
25 million people die during 25
million people died in World War Two,
uh,
most of them in the war,
but lots also installing,
installing these camps.
But La,
a lot of partisans,
uh,
lost their lives picking
off German soldiers.
In the case of Poland,
and it's a,
in the third edition,
there'll be more on on,
on this.
Um,
and they got scarcely a mentioned.
Uh,
the Polish had a home,
a home army,
as they called it,
of about 300,000 people.
By the end of the war,
uh,
and the,
um,
the Warsaw ghetto,
a rose up,
uh,
and,
and was crushed with 12,000 deaths and
with thousands of other people sent away
to the camps,
uh,
in 1943 and then the war saw uprising.
Uh,
one of the reasons that Warsaw,
the worst were all be on
Friday and go fairly often,
uh,
was just,
there was nothing left because
the uprising was crushed and,
and thousands and thousands of people,
uh,
lost,
lost their lives.
Um,
it was,
I just reviewed a book actually
for the Boston Globe about,
uh,
called Ghetto Washdot,
which is an interesting book by a man
called Gordon what to teach us in,
in Illinois.
Um,
and it's about the,
the low the woods,
uh,
Lod Dz ghetto.
And it's a,
you know,
it's a,
it's a tragic all too familiar tale.
It doesn't really do with resistance
because it was impossible,
but it was about the German ideas of
creating this area in the city in watts,
which was a big guy,
industrial town,
and still is in Poland.
And of course what they did is
they put all the juice into the,
get into the ghetto,
uh,
which was several kilometers a square
a and then puts them to work making
uniforms and ear muffs and all sorts
of things for the German troops.
Uh,
and the story really the most
horrific aspect of it is,
is that the people in the ghetto,
they don't really know.
There's all these rumors about
what's happening outside.
Of course,
what's happening is the killing fields,
uh,
3 million Jews,
you know,
disappear in Poland,
in World War II,
uh,
3 million,
3 million.
Um,
and I'm gradually that day,
you know,
and some people before
they're being killed by them,
by the Nazis are forced
to write postcards,
Cherry Postcard saying all
is well here in these camps,
everything is just delightful.
And of course then they're executed.
Um,
but gradually it's,
it's about the whore.
The mounting a horror of the people
who live there is that they see close,
stacked up outside the ghetto that they
could recognize as having been on people
they know,
they knew who had been
shipped away to the camps.
And it's really just,
I don't know,
it's just an a,
it's the whole thing.
So all right.
So horrendous than it was with us today.
Um,
that obviously it was more a,
it was easier to resist in
places in which you can hide.
And when I talk about France,
the reason that,
and I sent this term around
you call the French resistors,
the Mucky,
sad or even just a lay McKee is because
they were able to hide in brought behind
brush,
uh,
called Mckee,
which are more about this later.
Uh,
so resistance in Belgium,
which is the flat country outside of,
around the Argon was very,
very difficult,
uh,
in,
because there was hardly a
hill this more than a hump in,
in,
uh,
in Denmark.
But yet it was the Danes I in
Copenhagen who saved the Jews,
who got them out with the
help of a German officer and,
and,
and was able to get them
to just across the very,
uh,
narrow straits to model in,
in,
um,
uh,
in Sweden.
Um,
and other countries had the,
had the resistances as well.
And all of those can't be recovered,
uh,
now,
in a short amount of time.
Why not us?
But to have this class here actually,
because it has a label on it,
not supposed to have
this glass here at all.
Um,
but so I guess what I'll,
what I'll do is I want to talk about
France and about the resistance there now
until about 1969,
1969 a year that I can remember Altamont,
uh,
you know,
the mets win the,
the series a but more important,
uh,
protests against the war
in the United States,
uh,
and moaning,
dissatisfaction with,
uh,
was United States foreign policy.
I mean,
I can remember that very,
very well,
but until 1969,
uh,
there in France,
the official line was
virtually everybody resisted.
A few elites,
a few notables,
rural Leitz,
uh,
collaborated period.
Um,
and the official line was one,
of course,
it was very closely tied to gall
ism because Charles de Gaulle,
the big guy,
uh,
he,
you know,
his voice crackles over,
uh,
June 18th,
you know,
an 1840,
and he calls on France to resist it.
And a part of the myth that everybody
resisted or almost everybody in few people
collaborated,
I had to do with the
official goal is policy,
which is that the Gaullist resistant.
And they were that Charles de Gaulle,
this of mystical,
you know,
body of Charles de Gaulle,
the greater the body being greater
than the sum of all its parts,
uh,
led France,
which essentially liberated itself.
Um,
and of course that that's
completely not true.
And that also what that forgot about
was the fact that the communists were
enormously important in the resistance
and more about that in a while there was
a film made,
a documentary,
I think in about 1953.
I've never actually seen it.
And it had to do with the Jews.
It had to do with what happened
to the Jews and France.
It was conveniently forgotten that
the Jews in Paris who were arrested,
uh,
in the Monterey and the Jewish section of,
with Paris and in other places
too were arrested by the,
by the French police.
The Germans would have
been happy to do it,
but they didn't need to because the
French police were so eager to do that.
And in this film there was a,
uh,
Jews and other people and communists
and other people who were sent away were
packed off to a place called dual c,
which is a,
if you've ever taken the rer and from
the airport or to the airport to Wasi
airport in Paris who've
gone through John C,
and that was a transit camp.
And in transit camps,
rather like Mylene are Mechelen in,
in Belgium or vest Westbrook,
Westbrook,
I guess it's called an in,
uh,
in the Netherlands,
quite near the German border.
These camps were run
by French Belgians and,
um,
uh,
and Dutch.
They were not run by the Nazis.
The Nazis would have been happy to do it.
But,
but the local populations
and local collaborators,
collaborators,
we're doing that.
Uh,
and in this film made
in 1953 in the original,
there's UCLA,
a French gendarme who's
guarding the Jews at drone.
See now in the documentary
that was finally released,
somebody has reached in and plucked him
from the film and he simply disappears.
It's doctored.
So the French gendarme with his friends.
Sharn dom had a gendarme hat isn't in
the film because the myth was a course
that,
that the Jews were taken away and,
and,
and uh,
by the Germans and the Communists,
resistors were shot by the Germans and
the Gypsies and gay people were taken
away by the Germans were
arrested by the Germans and that,
that the France resisted in,
didn't collaborate.
Now two events.
Well,
let me also tell you a story.
Two stories.
Um,
when I was,
I hope I didn't say this the first day
when I was trying to get you interested
in learning about where we're too,
but when I worked at a place called Tula,
t u l l e,
a,
Iran,
I was doing my research for
my dissertation long ago.
And all that.
And,
um,
I would go down,
I couldn't have any money.
I go down by,
you know,
ice cream cone for lunch and,
and,
uh,
every day.
And I started talking to this guy and
I didn't speak French very well and,
and,
uh,
um,
but I knew that there were a lot of
people hung their 99 men were hung.
And,
uh,
because the,
the,
the Germans left the Maki,
the resistors are very active there.
Andre model whole with a great
group of the great writer was,
was active and in place,
what are some ta near there.
And one day the Germans
all left and then the,
everybody came out and started party and
the Germans came back and they hung 99
men from polls in two.
And one day I was there and,
and this guy was telling me this
story about how he had hidden,
he'd gone up,
it's,
uh,
it's a little what?
Real whiny town in a valley.
And he'd gone up and hidden with the,
you know,
you got house here.
And so he got room under the house.
And so he was able to hide
and escape because he was 16,
he would have been hung.
Um,
and this woman came up and I,
and I was eating my ice cream cone
and she ordered an ice cream cone.
And so the guy suddenly said,
well,
Madame Wa,
uh,
dupont,
you remember that day,
don't you?
Oh,
she said,
oh,
I sure do.
They hung my husband from that poll.
You know,
how every day you could
live with that and just,
you know,
talk about that as if you were
discussing where you would,
you know,
bought something in the sale.
But the next step to thinking about that
is who in France made all those things
possible?
Who was helping the,
the Germans do that.
And the answer is that lots of people,
collaborative,
lots of people got what they wanted on
a platter because of the Nazi victory.
And the same people who were shrieking
better healers and bloom in 1936 got
exactly what they wanted.
And Marshall [inaudible],
who was a rabid anti-semite,
became his national revolution,
was essentially aim to do in,
to do in France what Hitler had done in
Germany and what other petty despots had
done in other places.
Some not so petty like Hitler.
They got what they wanted.
So how do the official line
gets shaken by reality?
Uh,
how did this happen?
Second story,
I have a friend who was still a lawyer
in Paris and I've known him for a long,
long,
long time.
And he was too young to remember,
but his,
his older brother who's
dead now remembered when,
when the Germans came to
his house in the suburbs,
a place called Lupo,
who's her mom took away the
father who was a Greek Jew.
Uh,
and of course he was
taken away and it was,
was killed.
I mean,
he ended up in one of the camps.
They don't know what happened to them now.
The Germans didn't just come
to that house by chance.
The Guy was denounced as a Jew
by the policemen in that town.
And after the war,
every Saturday when,
uh,
you know,
this lady went to the widow,
went to the market,
she walked by and saw this
policeman directing traffic,
the same guy.
Nothing ever happened to him.
Nothing ever happened to him,
but it's,
well,
how did the official version
get eliminated by historical
reality histories have
their histories.
How did that happen?
Where there are two events that are
kind of key and they're both in,
in what I sent around.
One is the movie,
the sorrow and the pity,
which I mentioned in here before,
which was described as a to six pack
movie in the old days when I used to show
it here,
because the last four and a half hours,
it was a documentary made
for French television,
uh,
by Max Office.
It was never shown on
French television till 1981.
Why?
Because it was a documentary
in which collaborators,
there's a sort of a local notable
called Christiane dilemmas.
Yeah.
Who describes in his smoking,
smoking in his fancy
jacket in the chateau.
Why he fought alongside the Nazis on
the eastern front in the Waffen ss.
And it's about collaboration.
And resistance,
terror,
tales of,
of,
of true heroism,
but also of,
of repressed memory.
There's a great scene in which they're
walking through the school and,
and you know,
they ask about,
you know,
about the teacher teacher who disappeared
and they don't even remember about it.
They don't remember it.
The guys are being interviewed,
they've conveniently forgotten.
And so the sorrow and the pity,
the sugarhill a PTA,
I was never shown our French TV till 1981.
Uh,
it,
I mean,
it's a fantastic take us too long.
I should have never shown it.
I started showing it twice,
you know,
I mean in,
in sections,
I mean,
and also it's kind of dubbed and it's
very hard to understand that he either in
French or in English,
but it's,
it's a monument.
It's a monument,
not just because it's a,
you know,
a driving forceful documentary.
But if,
because it helped France rediscovers past
fabulous and talking about the role of
the,
of the Communist Party.
And again,
I'm not a communist,
but I'm telling you,
the Communist Party at an
enormous role and the resistance,
and there's a great scene where these two,
these two peasants for it's,
most of it was about Claremont fit home.
The area is based on the,
uh,
the Avaya town of Claremont Hall.
Um,
and,
uh,
there's this great scene where these
two peasants out in the countryside and
they say a nuisance who's
you'll come to a van were red,
like the wine we're drinking.
Uh,
and it,
you know,
it's a fabulous,
fabulous,
fabulous thing.
And of course,
there's the inevitable scene at the
end where we're pro were women who were
called indelicately,
a horizontal collaborators,
uh,
were,
had their head shaved and we're being,
being paraded through the town
that happened all over the place.
They told him,
news is what you call it in
French than a marriage conference.
But that,
but,
and in the end there's,
there's a,
uh,
Mojica Chavela.
Yay.
Now your grandparents will know who
Maria [inaudible] was because he kind of
represented,
uh,
the front in the American imagination,
what France was.
He was a crooner,
he was a singer who had,
was born in,
uh,
in many more,
Tom,
which is in a,
in a proletarian edge of Paris,
uh,
right near Radio,
pee off the singer was when
your grandparents will have
heard of also people way
before my time.
Um,
but at the end,
you know,
he,
at the end of the movie,
they have him and he's wearing this little
crooning suit and he says in English,
he says,
well,
you know,
there are these rumors that I was,
uh,
that I was a singing for the Germans,
but I just want to tell you that
I was only singing for z boys.
That is for the,
the prisoners of war.
And he was dealing with
his own past as well.
And,
and,
uh,
Francois,
me to hall,
President of France,
14 years,
beginning in 1981 when he was inaugurated,
uh,
the cameras follow him through the Pontiac
and he follows him by where the heart
or some part of a genre
has this left but false.
Want me to Ron?
When he was dying,
he came to grips with his own past.
he too,
like France.
He said there was a moment
when I was not a resistor,
which he became a resistor,
but there was a moment that he had
celebrated Vishi and somebody had found a
picture of him in a right wing rally in
1936 or 37 of which there were many in
Paris.
And he too came to grips with his past.
So this all started,
the history of history
started in the 1970s.
Now I'm,
the second event,
uh,
was a book published by my
good friend Robert Paxton,
who's was about 10 years older than me,
probably more than that.
And he wrote a book called
Vichy France published in 1972
and Vichy France was,
could not use French archives
because they weren't available.
There's a 50 year rule
and French archives,
but there is also a site,
we're talking about the mutinies that,
you know,
the mutinies weren't available.
Well after 50 years had passed I after
after the mutinies in World War One,
he,
so he used captured German documents,
not French documents because
they weren't available to them.
And what he did in this book was to
show what Vishi and pay Taz national
revolution fuck they
were doing and why many,
many people collaborated.
Uh,
there's a,
a more recent book by
a guy called Phillip,
a big Aha that I use in the seminar in
Vichy that I do from time to time junior
seminar.
Uh,
which explores more deeply using
these archives that are now available.
The whole question of a collaboration.
But the point that Paxton made is that
he demolished the shield argument,
the argument that that pay town and the
national revolution had saved the French
stake and that they were a shield.
If it wasn't for Vishi worst things would
have happened when Merissa Popol pap o
m I went on trial over 80 years of age
one on trial for having signed away the
lives of many Jews and ball Dole
where he worked in the prefecture.
He said this made the same argument.
He said,
I was a good bureaucrat.
My superiors liked me,
and if it hadn't been for me,
more Jews would have been been a shipped
away to draw SSI or more directly to
the camps.
And he was condemned.
And he died a couple of years ago.
He was under house arrest.
The most amazing part of
the whole trial was when he,
we managed to escape actually at age 80.
People drove him to the Swiss border
and they found him in a fancy Swiss
restaurant and brought him back.
But Paul had gone onto a very
distinguished career as a bureaucrat,
uh,
in,
the fourth and fifth republics.
Uh,
it had as did a lot of other subtle,
a lot of other bastards
such as a honeyboo buscape,
uh,
who,
was a prefect of police.
Um,
but the argument was the shield argument,
if it wasn't for us,
things would have been worse.
But as Paxton wrote,
very,
very memorably that that [inaudible]
might have provided continuity for the
French state,
but not for the French
nation and the French nation.
What was in his,
I hope,
and I'm proud to say,
uh,
based on liberty fraternity equality,
and they take those off
the coins and it becomes,
you know,
uh,
[inaudible],
cove,
I,
uh,
family,
you know,
country work.
Uh,
you can used to be when I was there,
you know,
and as a kid you could see these
still these little coins from,
from Vichy that they transformed into,
um,
into song team and Paxton's book packs.
And once I saw him when I was in Brussels,
I saw him on the TV show,
my wife and I did.
And he knows where there's
typical French shows,
shows where they'll have,
it'd be about world war
one or World War Two.
And they'll have,
have,
uh,
somebody who remembered the war,
somebody who was in the war,
uh,
somebody who didn't even
know what was going on,
you know,
and all this stuff.
And they interview them and some guy
got up this or right wing guy and there
were protests against packs,
is pro,
uh,
presence by skinheads.
And they got up and said,
you know,
Mrs Paxton,
what could you possibly
know about the war?
You were only 12 years old during the war,
but Paxton became,
this was an important part
of the history of history.
And when he was introduced
at this all been,
uh,
he was introduced by a guy
called a historian called,
um,
Isaiah Ma.
And he said,
when he introduced me,
he said,
Mr,
don't sign certain sauce,
visit to the costume telephones.
You know,
in a certain sense you Paxton
are the conscience of France.
So these two events are,
are,
are important in the emergence
of what historian Adi was.
So Russell calls the Vichy syndrome.
And then if Vichy was
conveniently forgotten,
uh,
because of gall ism or because of not
wanting to remember the bad things that
happen,
uh,
the collaborators,
the eager Antisemites,
uh,
The v now have a sense
since the early 1970s,
people are obsessed with Vichy and there's
all sorts of good work been done on,
on Vichy,
uh,
in the whole period of
resistance and collaboration.
Paxton,
once he estimated in that book that
2% of the French population resistant,
uh,
my friend John Suites who did a book
called choices and Vichy France,
great title and which he looked at
Claremore fair home because that was what
the,
the movie,
the sorrow and the pity would focused on,
he estimates that it,
depending on how you define resistance,
people that refuse to get off the
sidewalk when a German officer,
a past or,
or people that you know,
whistled it in the documentaries,
uh,
that the German newsreels
before the movie in the theater,
that there's something like
16 or 18% of the population,
uh,
resistant.
Uh,
it's a more charitable
definition of resistance,
but the fact is that I won't talk
more too much more about this,
but the collaboration was widespread.
It was not simply an elite.
The elites were more apt to collaborate
earlier in the war later in the war.
The kinds of people who join the militia,
uh,
which formed in January,
1943,
which was the French
equivalent of the Gestapo,
uh,
tended to be sort of down and out.
There were the kinds of
people who in France,
in Germany joined the SS,
many of them,
you know,
in the 1920 sod as a
form of social mobility,
there's a really good film called lock
Luciana that I haven't seen in years
about somebody who,
who between his ears
there wasn't very much.
And the resistance doesn't want
him because he's just kind of a,
you know,
an idiot.
It doesn't believe in anything.
Uh,
but the militias very happy to have them.
And it's about what happens to him in,
uh,
in the southwest of France
during the postpone trial,
which was maybe about eight years ago,
something like that.
Uh,
there was one time they interviewed a
German officer who is still alive and they
said,
well look,
uh,
you know,
what are your memories of,
of a pop?
Oh and the militia,
he said,
well we got,
we got a,
a guy,
you know,
we arrested a French guy
and we rather liked him.
We wouldn't turn him over to
the militia cause I mean these,
cause they would torture him.
So hideously,
of course,
the Germans were capable of
and did all over the place.
Torture people hideously,
no doubt about that,
but the militia were genuinely,
genuinely bad,
bad,
bad guys.
Uh,
and they,
um,
uh,
they,
I mean,
you saw this in luck
home Luciana little bit.
I mean that,
that restaurant scene is so
crucial in lacome Luciana.
That's,
that is really the essence of,
of,
of that film is in Luke home.
Luciana is the restaurant
scene when they're,
when they're in there.
So,
um,
you know,
collaborators were
everywhere and you know,
at the end of the war,
um,
probably about 25,000
people were executed.
Uh,
after very short trials are simply
gunned down near where we live.
In l dash a there was a priest,
um,
in a,
in a village not too far away from us.
And He,
um,
he had,
he had Dave [inaudible]
who was a real fascist,
uh,
to lunch.
And after the war,
uh,
they put them up against his
own church and gunned him down.
Uh,
have,
I have an acquaintance a long
time ago with one of their,
um,
worked in the archives.
And the most where I
spent a lot of time and,
and he,
uh,
was a,
a young man then,
and it was a refugee from an Ohioan.
And after the war,
everybody was celebrating where
he lived in a place called sadly,
or not alone,
the decor,
no blog,
which is near,
um,
uh,
limos and they're all partying.
And this little village,
which is a little town really,
that's the 12 kilometers
away from the emotion.
Somebody said,
where's the gendarme was
sold people down the river.
And someone said,
he's got an aunt in limos.
So they left all the cast
of wine that were left.
They marched into the most,
went to the aunt's house,
get the guy hauled him out,
put him at the beginning of this,
this procession,
joyous but also deadly serious procession,
serving enraged Sharevari,
uh,
chair Avari.
Uh,
and they got him back to
where he'd done great damage.
She put him against the wall and
then he went back to partying.
Uh,
so lots of,
there were lots of settling of scores.
I mean,
sometimes not everybody who had
their scores settled deserved it.
There were cases of people who were
misidentified or simply there were
rivalries,
but you know,
lots of people got theirs.
As for marshal Petain
what happened in p town?
Of course you can,
he's put on trial.
He,
you know,
he gave the original,
uh,
he was an old,
old man.
They said,
you can't execute an old,
old man.
He [inaudible] he wasn't at all.
Uh,
but you can't execute an old man
who was the hero Verdun done.
Can you,
uh,
so they,
put them on.
I,
they,
um,
uh,
put,
um,
can host confinement on an island and
there were still people trying to get to
the island,
which is off the coast of Brittany
and bring back his bones to veer done.
That happened only about
10 or 12 years ago.
And so France,
uh,
you know,
it's took a lot longer than the kind
of gunning people down and the tribe,
the trials that went on after the war,
uh,
for France to come to grips
with is past now resistance.
I just do something wrong.
What happened to,
Oh,
this is all right.
All right.
Um,
is that too loud?
Sorry.
Yeah.
So,
okay.
Um,
resistance.
What do we know about resistance?
First of all,
uh,
obviously it was easier
to resist in the south,
uh,
than the north because of the topography.
One of the reasons why the,
the Germans occupied so-called free
France in November of 1942 a was the fact
that resistance that already started,
uh,
the first active case of resistance,
with,
with important consequences in Paris was
at the metro stop called Barb as well.
Schwab,
uh,
which is not one of those
places where the police,
especially as the Sarcozi was elected,
I have these la flew where they,
you know,
anyone of color as immediately
asked for their id and you know,
and,
and made it to stand there and
be humiliated by the police.
Uh,
but anyway,
back then somebody,
a gun down a German officer,
um,
and,
and gradually,
uh,
gradually acts of resistance.
Uh,
I started,
uh,
I,
to repeat what I said before,
the word Maki comes from a brush,
a very sick brush that's
in Corsica and in the,
what they call them fringe,
the guy.
He goes also in the sort
of rocky part of the south.
We have it wrong where we live too,
but it was just a sort of a metaphor for
places that you could hide because you
had to be out there hiding.
Uh,
and by 1944,
by certainly the spring of 1944 and
in many places earlier than that,
the mucky ruled at least at night,
during the day,
they didn't only twice in France
do they take on German foolish.
They tried to take on German,
a militarized units,
big units,
one near Claremont for hall,
and the other is [inaudible],
which is near Grenoble.
Uh,
uh,
you know,
we're going over near the Alps.
And of course they were just wasted.
They were just destroyed
a in a village near Aasa,
uh,
somebody denounced a people who were,
up in the hills up in
this event mountains.
And one day,
you know,
the motorized units come
and the parachutes common,
you know,
they're toast as the end of it.
And there were a bunch of slaughters
a down round where we live.
People don't like to
talk about what happened.
I wanted to interview somebody
who was a resistor in our village.
Um,
even though our village wasn't,
isn't where there were a
lot of resistance going on.
Um,
and I,
you know,
I wanted to talk to him cause I was
writing a book about our village called,
um,
uh,
I don't remember what it's called,
but,
uh,
meanwhile the Pierre,
um,
and,
uh,
he,
you know,
he agreed to come over and talk about
it and then he simply never showed up.
People didn't like to talk
about things like that.
He never did want to discuss it.
But,
uh,
I would say more resistance was
in the south than in the north,
though it's forgotten
often that there were,
it was a lot of resistance in Paris that
there was Jewish resistance in Paris
too.
I met a guy in Australia,
uh,
eight years ago who made a lot of money.
I'm making cakes and then went
back and got his phd in history.
Uh,
working with a friend of mine,
peer Mcphee,
and he wrote a book on the
Jewish resistance published
by Oxford Jewish was just
as in Paris,
a guy called Jack.
God layer,
uh,
who is,
is happily,
uh,
still around.
But the most famous cases
that you all know about,
of course,
are these resisters who
are living off the land,
uh,
in Oceania or in,
in the [inaudible] mountains or,
or a,
I mean,
anywhere that you could
hide there would be,
um,
but they,
they are often in French cities.
You can see plaque saying
resistors met here,
you know,
to organize resistance.
I mean,
that's what they did.
And they took big,
big chances,
uh,
because when they've,
for example,
blew up railroad tracks,
that's what,
there were so many communists,
resistors,
uh,
and,
and the comic,
the Communist Party had a big,
hold on,
on the shammy.
No,
we're railroad workers.
And so a lot of the,
when you go to railroad stations
won't lead anywhere you go.
You see huge lists.
Any railroad station you go to in France,
huge lists of people who
were killed during the war,
either fighting the resistance who were
shot because they were involved with
sabotage.
It doesn't take much to,
to blow up a track.
Uh,
and they did it all down
the Rhone valley constantly.
There was a woman who was
a big time collaborator and
the northern part of the l
dash where the office Aviva came from to,
with Ministry of Jua,
Minister of Jewish affairs,
totally unrepentant.
Um,
and that meant that he was
shipping Jews away to be killed.
That's what,
that's what he was doing.
And she was a collaborator and one day
she walked across the bridge and to go
shopping and other side of their
own and they blew her head away.
Uh,
uh,
but when you did that,
you knew that they were good.
They were going to pay you back so much.
It's when the hydro at k when I
went to see where Heidrick ones,
so it was assassinated near Prague.
And when Heidrick was assassinated by,
by a Czech resisters,
they took an entire village and killed
everybody in the village base called
ladies.
Everybody in the village,
hundreds and hundreds of
people were massacred.
They were capable of doing anything.
But the point is that there were in all
these countries that were people who
were very,
very happy to see that happen.
And if you go to Budapest,
when you see the shoes of all
the people that were pushed,
shot or are just thrown into the and
swirling river of swirling water of the
Danube,
you know,
as Hungarians pushing the Jews there.
And he was the Hungarian
shipping the Jews off to,
uh,
to Os fits.
Uh,
so they were people in every place who
are happy to see these things happen.
Uh,
and,
and the big lie of course in
Germany is people didn't know.
Of course,
people knew.
They knew,
and they knew.
And France to,
uh,
they,
they knew absolutely.
Uh,
and it fit into the xenophobia.
It's fit into v She's vision of what
France would be a vision in which the
Catholic Church would
have a much greater role.
There were two people executed
for abortion during the time.
A corporatist ethic where like
Mussolini's corporatism you delay,
eliminate class struggle by having
everybody in vertical organizations.
I,
everybody's,
uh,
you know,
happy to be French,
are having to be Italian
or happy to be German.
And you forget the fact that your employer
makes 10 times more than what you do.
Um,
the kind of embrace of peasants
TISM the resurgence of,
of Joan,
of Arc,
uh,
because Joan of arc became identified
with pay tie as saving France and all of
that.
Uh,
it's,
it's all very familiar stuff,
but so they had a plan and
national revolution was
something they wanted to do.
My good friend Eric Jennings,
who teaches a Toronto wrote a fantastic
book called Vichy in the tropics and he
looked at Guadalupe,
uh,
Indochina and Madagascar because in
those places Vishi you couldn't say,
well,
the Nazis made us do it because
there weren't any Nazis.
They're there,
no German troops in those places.
And yet they're in Vietnam.
There were 27 Jews and they desperately
are trying to find these 27 Jews to send
them to the death camp so far
away or to kill them themselves.
So,
uh,
it was the shield argument doesn't work.
Uh,
they collaborated a,
and in the end,
a lot of them got with
it what they want it.
Now as far as the resistance,
uh,
we've always focused on males because
the idea is you've got all these Spanish
refugees from the civil war,
from Franco,
and you've got all a working class people
and you've got peasants and they're
all,
all these males.
And they were there,
but somebody had to darn their socks.
Somebody had to provide them with food,
somebody had to carry messages and,
and uh,
it's more than just one of these old,
you know,
movie things over.
The very young attractive woman
is carrying a message and the,
and the,
and charming the guards so
they don't a Frisker uh,
or stop at all.
But that happened.
I mean,
you carry it.
You never had be so stupid
as to have a written message,
but you're carrying verbal messages in
place that you could hide foods such as
where we lived or out near where we live.
[inaudible]
somebody has to take these people food.
Uh,
and also the other thing is the
Catholic Church of it sounds like,
uh,
I mean business about
the pope helping Jews.
It's just sheer nonsense and nobody
should ever be tricked by that.
Uh,
but,
but I,
the complicated role of,
of the Catholic Church,
uh,
in France there was the archbishop of,
of Toulouse who was a very
courageous guy who said,
you know,
don't hurt anybody who,
who it was encouraging really resistance
implicitly and the Archbishop of Alby,
which is only an hour drive
if that from Toulouse,
he was an outright collaborator
and in many places,
Catholic clergy,
uh,
who are impinging leaders in their village
along with the school teachers were
very,
very important in uh,
in helping,
helping give a,
a moral kind of stamp
to acts of resistance.
There's a good book on the
resistance by a guy called HR QED,
word Rod,
QED word.
Uh,
he's got two books,
one about some resistance
and in urban areas,
particularly Leona and won't PDA
and how people kind of got together.
You had to be careful
about who you talk to.
You're waiting for a train.
The train is late cause it's the war,
you know,
you're kind of feeling each other out,
but you better be damn careful.
You're not talking to some denounced sir.
Uh,
and that you're,
you know,
you're toast if you talk
to the wrong person.
But it's about how you,
how you can make resistance happen.
It's about,
for example,
printing out,
uh,
just um,
fi,
uh,
little,
little typescript,
things that say do not come in here.
The Berlin Philharmonic Orchestra,
when they play in,
in Berlin,
I've ever play in Leon.
And all you do is you get on a
bus with those things and the bus,
you're in the back seat in the bus,
turns the corner.
He just let them go.
The wind takes them.
Uh,
but his other book that's really good
is called in search of the Mckee,
which is about,
uh,
precisely when I'm talking about,
it's about the resistance
in the south and looking at,
at people who,
uh,
who,
who resisted.
He has an interesting story.
There's a,
a couple of lot of villages
that were Protestant villages,
uh,
that suffered greatly during
all the wars of religion.
And a couple were no worthy.
And that,
that during the,
after the wars of religion that the
king had these huge mission crosses,
huge crosses of conquest
put up over the village,
which were essentially Protestant
and remain Protestant villages.
Did those signs help identify the
Catholic Church that had been the enemy of
those Protestants in the old days with,
with Vichy?
Quite possibly,
but it's what John Suites
called choices in Vichy,
France.
Things happen that made you take a choice.
Now,
what were one of those things?
The most important with the sto,
the STL,
the Soviets do two of Iob got 12,
which I wrote in the,
in the notes,
the service,
uh,
the,
the uh,
service in quotes,
uh,
obligatory work service.
And the deal was basically that if you,
if you agreed to go along to,
uh,
you know,
to work in a German factory,
uh,
that well,
they would let some prisoners of war going
all if it doesn't work out like that.
These people were fools.
Two people from our village
want one was dead drunk.
He thought somebody told
me he's going to a party.
So we got on a bus and the
next stop is the Rhineland.
And of course,
those people are wasted by,
uh,
by the bombing.
I mean,
cause the,
cause the allies are
the masters of the air,
uh,
for the last couple of years of the war.
And they systematically
devastate those factories.
And a lot of those people in the Sto,
uh,
that went left.
But what,
what the,
I mean,
are killed but left the earth.
But what the Sto did is it made people
take a choice because if you didn't show
up on the 9th of February,
you pick the date,
uh,
Nike 44,
you didn't go.
I,
if you're sitting in your village,
they're going to come and take.
So at that point,
choices and Vichy France,
I'm going to go into the resistance.
Big Choice.
You go into the resistance,
you know,
you live off the land.
Uh,
sometimes just a couple of people,
sometimes lots of people
of international mix.
Lots of polls were there,
lots of Spaniards.
But the,
most of the people were,
were French.
And one of the interesting things is
that the resistance itself did not,
unlike almost everything,
uh,
every put a big political van
in France since the revolution,
a to 1981 did not follow traditional lines
between right and left that left wing
regions to not have a
monopoly on the resistance.
There was tons of resistance in Brittany.
There was tons of resistance and Normandy
Eisenhower after the war said the
French Resistance,
uh,
was worth an entire
division or to division.
I can't remember exactly what he said.
And of course,
they help prepare their way,
enormity for the invasion of June 6th,
1944.
Uh,
so that old left right dichotomy
does not work in terms of regions.
It does work in terms of what people
were more likely to resist working.
People were more likely to resist,
uh,
because their unions had been broken,
by,
uh,
by Vishi,
because there were more apt to
have supported the Popular Front,
no to the France of the apparent TIF,
uh,
was the cry of the right in 1960 in 1936,
the no to the France of drinking
before lunch and all of this,
no to the France of,
of the Jew blossom better Hitler then,
then,
then bloom,
uh,
over and over again.
Um,
so working people and peasants who
liked the ones who said a new sound,
who's you're coming to van,
uh,
Eh,
that I mentioned before
are more apt to resist.
Now,
why does the Communist Party have such a
privileged role in the existence of the
resistance?
After the war?
They call themselves the
Party of 75,000 martyrs.
Now,
that may be an exaggeration,
but not by much because
whenever there was a shooting,
whenever there was a Nazi gun down,
whenever there was a railroad track,
a blown up,
uh,
carrying munitions,
carrying soldiers,
carrying whatever,
whenever they couldn't get through,
who are the ones who are first being
when they go to the mayor and says,
who do you want shot communists
would be the first to go always.
And the forts around parish,
Tony's other places that were communists
put up against the wall all the time.
They were the most likely to resist,
uh,
along with other Gaullist,
you know,
Joel Moo loud dude.
The prefect of the Illawarra
who is hideously tortured,
uh,
without revealing any secrets was,
was,
was one who was sent out to
try to unify the resistance.
But why were the communists so effective?
Well,
because the Communist Party or
Aki are organized into cells.
We still get little little,
uh,
notices in our mailbox saying
that the communist party,
the sell of Bala Zuke where we live,
you know,
all four people in the communist party
are going to meet together and to drink
illegal wine,
to drink a wine called
clamp tall or whatever.
And I was once asked to describe the,
the fall of capitalism
and how it had to say,
well,
it's really not falling yet,
but,
but the point is,
is that that,
that the,
they were already organized and that
these networks were not destroyed by the
war,
uh,
were not destroyed by they existed.
The comradeship you,
if you were a communist,
you'd been a communist since the 1930s.
You trusted those people,
you are apt to fall in with them.
There were two people,
one of whom is still alive.
We spent a lot of time in prison in Paris,
a painter who's now,
he's 95.
He's a friend of mine and he and his wife,
the first vacations that they took,
a double bike,
they drove,
they paddled all the way from
Paris down to our village,
which they had subsequently
made their home.
They joined the Communist Party
in 1933 and 1935 and they,
he was a big resister,
big time resist,
who was lucky.
Damn lucky to escape with his life.
He was scheduled to be
executed and he wasn't.
He painted people in the prison
and I've seen his paintings.
Uh,
now the socialists were
an organized and that way.
And so sometimes after the war,
the comedy,
he said,
Aha.
The Socialists don't,
uh,
you know,
they weren't the big resistors.
Well,
many did.
Individually.
Leon Blum was lucky not
to have an executed.
Uh,
he survived the war in prison.
He was put on trial at a
place called her and you know,
right in there,
20 more fit.
Huh?
He survives the war.
Uh,
but there was a Catholic resistance also.
I have a very old friends,
I mean old,
much older than me,
who,
uh,
you know,
went from the,
the captain of the left wing Catholic
resistance into the Communist Party,
you know,
in the Socialist Party.
They kind of normal trajectory of
those things among militants and the,
and they were,
you know,
they were,
they were resistors.
Uh,
also Protestants were at where are more,
no,
are,
are more known for having resistant
because of some very famous events.
Uh,
but remember only 5% of
the French population,
there's Protestant,
there's a village called Lou shamble,
Su [inaudible],
which is right near all dash.
And they had a cottage industry of making
fake ID for Jewish children from the
online insanity and who were kept in
this small village and who were saved,
who were saved because of these people.
And whenever the Germans
would come through,
which wasn't that off,
often,
they would hide the children or they'd go,
they'd go to the Germans
to go through and said,
my God,
there are a lot of children.
Well,
these are practicing Catholics,
aren't they?
Well,
they weren't.
They were PR practicing.
Uh,
uh,
Protestants.
Uh,
but,
uh,
it,
it's,
uh,
so those are the more famous cases.
Uh,
but lots of people resisted.
Lots of people resisted.
Uh,
but lots of people collaborated and
many other people were in different.
That's the way it is.
I want to close with a story of orders
are gone because somebody who wrote this
book called,
um,
Margaret village,
both in French.
I got,
she got him out and in,
in English with cal press,
with somebody who took this course
with me long time ago and wasn't as her
college,
uh,
Sarah Farmer.
And she wrote a book.
There is a village nearly Moje where,
uh,
when the Germans were leaving,
they were leaving,
getting the hell out,
going north after this
massacre in to that,
I alluded to.
Suddenly they show up in the village
and they shoot all the men and they put
them in,
in the women and the children in
the church and they killed them.
They blow the church up.
One woman escaped through
the little window,
very thin lady escaping through the little
window behind and they destroyed the
entire village.
And so people who had taken the tram to
the market and the most came back and
there was enough.
Everybody was dead,
dead,
and they left this village
standing the way it all,
it's still there now.
There's a center of memory.
One of my friends is the director of it.
Sarah Farmer wrote a book about it,
but the book,
what is important about it is
that this was the site chosen,
the site chosen to commemorate the war.
Why?
Because it was virgin.
No collaborater supposedly no resistors,
supposedly martyred village.
But what it,
it turned out more complicated than that.
It's a wonderful book.
Margaret Villa,
Sarah Farmer.
But what chose the complexity of it is,
what happened afterward is that the people
in this village who were gunned down,
the women and children's were killed,
were killed by some Germans,
but lots of them were Alsatian who were
brought directly into the German army.
And so they went on trial in 1953 and
there were riots in the mile and straws
Buhler that they should
ever be put on trial.
They called themselves the
multigrain in spite of ourselves.
Uh,
and there were riots in the
most that the penalties were,
were,
were so mild that,
that,
that some of them were let go if they
had not joined voluntarily and the others
went to jail.
But that's what's,
and,
and the man who ordered the massacre,
a guy called Lammerding,
there were various attempts
to kidnap him from the,
from Germany and bring
them back to France.
But he died a natural death
in the 1970s or 1980s.
But this was the enormous,
ironic complexity of the whole thing of,
of getting into the
history of the history,
of trying to understand what happened
during those years that some of the
murderers in this case where else
session and therefore French until,
until Hitler invades in 1940.
So collaboration and resistance,
great subjects for study,
but heartbreaking.
Just,
just absolutely tragic.
Uh,
and the,
you know,
the,
the Nazis would be happy to do all,
all a of stuff on their own.
But the xenophobia,
the antisemitism led to those cases of
the guys going up the stairs and Paris
and other cities and all the
pop on signing lives away,
uh,
were French.
And so France as another country's,
it's happening and Belgians who
are coming to the grips with,
with their past.
So it's been a sad pleasure
to talk about that.